Harry comes over to London in a couple
of roles he's the son of King Charles
III a man who he still respects and has
a great adoration for despite the
fractures in their relationship but he's
also thief in line to the throne and a
counselor of state so it's important for
him to be here in a constitutional
position regardless of how he feels
about his family but I hear from sources
he is looking forward to being part of
this moment despite things of the past
that have happened of course this trip
will be Prince Harry's first time seeing
his family members face to face since
the release of spare but it won't be the
first time that he's spoken with some of
them in fact Harry's had several
conversations with his father over the
month since the release of the book
largely about the coronation itself and
of course it matters to do with Frogmore
cottage which
no longer have the keys for any week now
but of course that doesn't change things
between Harry and William it's been a
stone called silence between the two
brothers and that's continued since
Queen's funeral through the release of
the Netflix series the book and of
course now this trip to London and I
don't think things will change in terms
of Harry's role as a member of the royal
family this is the last time he's
required to be here in the UK for some
time but he does have upcoming visits
he'll be back in June for a court case
against one of the British tabloid
newspapers and that does provide an
opportunity to perhaps pick up on the
conversations that he didn't have whilst
he was here during the coronation there
is hope there and of course he's back
later in the summer for the Invictus
games in Germany which isn't that far
away from London so anything could
happen I don't think anyone on either
side is ruling anything out but our
sources do say on the sussex's side the
ball is very much in the Royal Family's
Court Harry's trip to London is in and
out in a Flash in fact people around him
are working as hard as they can to find
the quickest way into the country and
the quickest way out he's really only
coming here for the ceremony so any
hopes for a reconciliatory moment or a
private Heart to Heart between Father
and Son or any of his family members I
think they'll be waiting for another
time
[Music]
thank you